all right so we've been talking a lot
about sort of the revenue and ad side of
the YouTube advertiser boycott but
YouTube has actually been changing
around a lot of features on their
website so I want to make sure that you
just as a viewer of our channel are
doing everything that is available to
you to support our channel and to help
us in the YouTube algorithm so first and
foremost not everybody is subscribed to
our Channel right some people actually
search out the David Pakman show YouTube
channel each time they want to watch
videos so please please please hit the
subscribe button and make sure you are
subscribed because one of the main
indicators to YouTube as to what
channel's videos might be recommended is
how many subscribers that Channel has so
please even if you don't use the feed
and manually come to our channel each
day hit the subscribe button now number
two I hear from some people who say
David I'm subscribed but I'm not
actually being notified when you put out
new content or when you go live so there
is a very simple explanation for that on
the desktop version of the show you will
see as pointed to by this red arrow a
bell icon when you click that bell icon
a window will pop up related to
notifications and that window looks like
this and when that window pops up you
want to make sure that send me all
notifications for this channel is
selected now you can actually go even
further than that you can then click on
manage settings and when you do that you
will be able to select whether you want
email only push only or push and email
notifications if you often watch YouTube
on mobile then you might want push
notifications for when we go live you'll
be notified on your phone one other note
on this if you are on mobile there are
now when you use the Bell button you
were still given three options as to
what degree of notifications you want
and there's all occasional or none if
you hit the Bell and you hit occasional
you may not be notified about live
streams which a lot of people like or
you may not be notified about all of our
videos so the best thing you can do to
actually be notified when we put out new
videos and content
is if you're on mobile hit the Bell and
then click on all these things have
nothing to do with the ad boycott they
have everything to do with making sure
that as many of our subscribers or as
possible are actually getting the
content that we put out because the most
views that we can get the most more
subscribers that we can get YouTube ad
boycott aside the more powerful that the
david pakman show YouTube channel will
be